as promised the film buddy games it's
available
in theaters and on demand digital and
dvd right now
marks his directorial and writing debut
he also plays the role of bob father in
this film
along with olivia munn and dax shepard
nick swartzen was phenomenal
and kevin dillon and so much more our
friend josh duhamel back here on the
rich asian show how are you josh
rich thanks for having me thanks for
coming on this program i greatly
appreciate it um
now this film josh before we get into
everything else here let's get right
into it
um buddy games it is your directorial
and writing debut
it's a it's about a group of friends who
come back together to play
the buddy games and a lot of these
competitions are
um they're interesting let's put it that
way
uh josh they're interesting i i i i give
you the floor on
on some of these games that you play
that's a very tame way to put it yes
they are interesting obviously uh we
we heightened some of the events for for
cinematic value yes
uh we don't actually do a lot of the
things that you'll see in this movie but
uh we do some pretty crazy stuff my
buddies and i have been doing this for
i don't know 20 years or so and i've
known these guys since i was
like some of them since kindergarten
right and and we had an idea to write
this script
a few years ago and we wrote it and
decided to uh
take it in and we ended up you know wwe
loved it and
and let me direct it and it's it's you
know
my my goal here was to do two things
one was to tell a story about friendship
and how those friends
uh become more valuable as we all get
older and you know there's
some real underlying uh themes here but
you know mostly i wanted to do something
that
that really pushed the envelope i wanted
there to be moments in this thing where
people are like oh my god i can't
believe they just went there and there's
some stuff you just can't unsee in this
movie and it's
we've shown it now a few times in
theaters and people absolutely lose
their minds which is
what i was rooting for so let me let me
let me walk through one by one here and
you tell me if you've actually done this
or your friends have actually done this
with you
uh and or you just made it up for the
film if that's okay josh
oh please do okay first one is you take
a laxative
uh before going into a bar and hit on
girls before
uh the laxative kicks in is that a is
that something you've done
no we have not actually done that but
that would be a pretty fun one we might
try that one next year
okay but that is uh that is what is done
in this film well the idea is you got
to win the challenge you gotta everybody
have to down a little bottle of
laxatives you gotta go
yeah you gotta get get a girl to buy you
a drink you gotta get him on the dance
floor and you gotta get him to
give you a kiss on the lips and if you
do all that before you you know lose it
you win the competition okay
uh here's another one eyebrow stuff
don't hold on a second
hold on a second here's another one uh
playing chicken with a komodo dragon
with
meat strapped to your head last one to
bail wins do you got on that one josh
we actually have not done that one
either that is uh that was one that we
made out for cinematic
uh value it was uh the idea there is
that you
you know strap a pork chop is pretty
self-explanatory you strap a pork chop
to your head
everybody sticks their head up up this
you know inside of this hole so the only
thing showing is your head
release the komodo dragon the last one
who stays above the whole lens
um so what in this film is something
that you have done i've just named a
couple of them i don't want to give up
too many
um but what have you done in real life
what is in buddy games
well i mean this last year every year we
we do
everything from ping pong to whiffle
ball to golf okay
in all the basics but there's always one
competition that's just outrageous this
last year
we uh bob the guy who i play in the
movies yes
made us uh all stripped down into our
underwear gave us a nut cup
and a helmet and you had to stand there
with aren't your arms
you know spread wide both ways and the
other team would shoot
a paintball from about 20 yards away and
if you flinched you lost the point and
if you got hit
you know depending on what part of the
body you got hit you you would get a
certain amount of points so
that's the kind of uh you know
adolescent behavior that we revert
immediately back to as soon as we all
get together and again i want to give
anything away in the film but in real
life what do you win
when you say you get points like what
does this bragging rights man
bragging rights that's it
that's it it's not even like a plaque or
a trophy that you could just point to
and say this is what i got because i
didn't flinch when a paintball hit me in
the nuts like
literally well you do you do
no you don't even really get a trophy at
one point there was a trophy but that i
don't even know what happened to that
thing so
yeah just bragging rights and now that
we're actually talking it out loud i'm
just going to think that there's
something wrong with me
[Laughter]
josh dumel here on the rich eisen show
and how many of these
i'm i'm assuming the number is zero but
how many of these
is something nick schwartzen said that's
too much i can't do it
zero that guy is as fearless as they
come i'm not even kidding you're him and
him and back at all i mean james roday
is amazing
and these guys you know it's not just
screwball stuff either it is it is
outrageous especially the stuff we're
talking about we didn't even get into
the pina colada part of it but
um but yeah it it it's
i truly got i wanted guys who would come
in we only had 18 days to shoot it so we
had to go quick
i wanted guys who were uh you know
actors first but also comedic and could
improvise and i let them just i just
kind of let them go you know we had a we
had parameters that we had to keep
within the scene to push
the story forward but you know i wanted
these guys to feel
sort of creatively liberated as they
went and that's what i
that's the way i love to work and and
that's kind of the environment that we
set
and they came in and just laid it down
and it was so much fun it was like
summer camp
so did you at least attempt to get dame
judi dench in the cast
streep did you ever go in that well what
do you think i did i did but apparently
she was busy
[Laughter]
just maybe just maybe the stunts were
just too uh
too easy for she wanted something more
challenging could be that josh you know
you know you know you know rick you you
could you'd be a good i've seen you run
that 40s
yes that would be a good contestant
you're always welcome man
i could do the one where you have to run
in protective gear with the arrows being
shot i could try that one
you know i could shut up that would be a
good one how about this one josh dumoul
here on the rich eisen show again uh his
directorial and writing debut buddy
games is available in theaters on demand
digital dvd
right now the insane obstacle course
that includes electric shocks and beer
chugging did you did you pick that one
up when you
when you showed up on the set of holy
moly recently
is that where you got that one from josh
no no i didn't actually i
i i you know i i scrubbed the internet i
found
some ridiculous stuff we got ideas and
then we sort of
you know molded them to the way we
needed them to play out in the movie but
yeah we just wanted to have this
and that actually does come from
something that it's a different group of
buddies that i met out here in la
who do this thing called trace hombres
and they do this giant obstacle course
that includes all kinds of crazy stuff
and that's
sort of where that idea came from but we
just kind of made a different version of
it for
for the movie but yeah you know this is
you know
this is the thing about this is that as
crazy as it sounds
it is truly something we all look
forward to every year and guys all over
the
world do stuff like this uh maybe not
this extreme
but you know i think it's important to
keep that kid alive
inside of you you know and i and and
mine is alive and kicking believe me
i just i love to sort of
first of all see my boys i love these
guys and you know
we just kind of immediately revert back
to our 16 year old cells when we get
together
it's just fun and i think that's okay
it's fun it's just a ton of fun
it's it's a laugh riot man the whole
thing um
body games i think it's a good time for
it too you know i think that
there's there's there's nothing but a
good time here and i think that you know
right now is a great time
to have this movie being come no doubt
we always worked on the world we just
want to get lost and just have fun and
forget about all
all you know real world stuff i mean i
had jared goff on last week
quarterback of the rams and he's in a
fantasy league with all his buddies from
back in the day just like you know i
mean i guess it's a version of buddy
games in a way
josh is that he said even though he's
not paying terrible attention to it but
he has a friend who is his general
manager
the loser of the league has got to do
something totally crazy
year in and year out two years ago it
was the loser of the league
had to go fly to gnome alaska for a day
and and last year it was
what was it the barstool chris has some
sort of a fight everywhere
they have rough and rowdy rough and
rowdy they had to go fight in the bar
stool rough and rowdy at the super bowl
like that's what they had to do
that's what what do you mean go fight
like a fist fight yes like like
boxing yeah like actually get in a ring
oh
and have to get get in an actual fist
fight competition with somebody because
you lost a fantasy football league
i mean people do this stuff sort of
stuff all the time and it's it's fun
it's just fun to see man yeah you know i
agree man i love that
those are my kind of guys right there i
bet so what how did you show up on the
set of holy moly did
honestly like i was watching that i
watch it with my kids we love it the
whole family does
and then just seeing you there uh i i
think it was
zac efron was in the crowd too it was
how did you wind up there
so my buddy tanner uh was competing in
it and and
you know they've got a they've got a
similar group of buddies kind of like
mine where they're very tight and they
all kind of hang out
right and he was on the show and they
said
dude you got to come and watch you got
to come watch counters on holy moly so i
went out there
and and i had no idea they were going to
put me on
air as soon as i get to like they they
knew that i was coming i guess
michael said i was like wait wait wait
i'm just here to support but you know
like
being the the pushover that i am i
agreed to do it next thing i know i'm
sitting next to rob riggle
in the booth and joe tested for it i
mean it was hilarious
it was amazing it was actually a really
fun time it was
uh that show again like it kind of is
the same
you know without the you know komodo
dragon but
it's a similar sensibility where it's
just like let's all get together
and do something that's really stupid
but it's fun
and there's a certain camaraderie to it
you know what i mean absolutely
absolutely i'm all for it and i don't
even apologize for it
it's it's part of it's you know it's
part of
you know when you grow up in north
dakota you gotta you gotta be
imaginative especially in the winter
and this is i think where we got these
these sick twisted senses of humors
is just you know out of sheer boredom
and you know the cold plunger of north
dakota in the middle of winter before i
let you go you think your vikings still
have a shot this year what do you think
what do you think i'm i'm i'm not
that confident you know they they have
games where they play well
um i think cousins is a
he's a passable quarterback if that's
the right term
i just don't think he's the kind of guy
that is going to take him
over the top um no offense to him or his
his abilities because he's a good
quarterback obviously i just
wish we had somebody like rogers or
mahomes but you know those guys aren't
exactly a dime a dozen no but dalvin
cook is
uh that version at running back i think
i think you got yourself a superstar we
have
we're we definitely have talent but we
also lost a lot of talent last year i
think that's
that that hurt us well lost a lot of
guys in the la are or the d-line
right uh olin's been a little beat up uh
you know picked up some good players but
just doesn't feel like we have enough to
really
do damage yeah justin jefferson and cook
together i think for years to come you
got
i mean if there's there is something
there and you're you're right if cousins
is the right trigger man then maybe you
can
make some run here i mean four and six
it's entirely possible
yeah they could they could make a run
and they do have talent i love zimmer i
do like the team and i don't even
dislike cousins
i just right i just have not been able
to buy all the way in
uh there's a kid out of north dakota
state have you been following him at all
that trey lance
tell me about him tell me more about him
i have heard of him and i've heard his
name
a lot he was a he was a true fresh wait
no he was a redshirt freshman last year
played uh played a player that you won
the walter payton award one
jerry rice reward first guy ever to do
that i think
right didn't have looked like 20 some
touchdowns zero interceptions
has a really nice arm and can move and
and he can improvise and
that's the guy that i think they need to
watch for is is you know
as much as i'd love to get a guy like
trevor lawrence he's gonna go to the
jets probably
is that your team it is uh josh and uh
everybody needs to back off from trevor
because he's the jets
that's he's he's the jets property you
don't go oh and 10
and then drop the ball this close to
getting him that's not happening man no
way you know he does have another year
of eligibility
bite your tongue damn it i'm selling
your movie for you come on now
hey listen i would like to see trevor
lawrence go i do like jets and i think
that you know they need
a guy like that to sort of come on
seriously like in new york city don't
you think he would be dynamite in new
york city
don't you think i do right but what what
what happened with the kid out of ufc
what's his name um
darnold i don't know the jet's broken
working out
they broke him in two brother all right
that's the problem though you can't it
doesn't matter what the quarterback you
gotta have the right
guys around to sort of coach them up too
no matter how good they are
right and i think they got to get that
right that is correct i think they will
i think you know the best of the best
will raise their hands and say i want a
shot here
so if they get a guy like trevor
lawrence i think that'll attract the
right kind of people to come and
you know groom them right but um if not
um maybe the young man that you're
touting right now could be a a quality
if you will
silver medal or bronze medal i don't
know but you know i want him to go to
the vikings i want i want trey lance
with the bikes he's from minnesota too
well then that would be somebody that
they got a trade to go get because i
don't think you're going to be close
enough i don't know maybe he'll drop i
don't know that wouldn't be a bad one
what a great choice that's the problem
the vikings they're always good enough
where they never get a great draft
they never get like that super high drop
pick right but we're always right there
we're kind of
middle upper pack uh and then
we haven't ever that i can remember
grabbed like a like a young quarterback
that we've been able to develop
we always get like somebody who's sort
of been kicked around a little well
uh you know there's still more football
to be played maybe you got a a run and
you're here and uh i i look forward to
everybody checking out buddy games in
theaters
on demand digital and dvd right now
um josh congrats on it's a fun movie
brother and olivia munn's in it as well
a lot of a lot of fun moments and just
have
have a good time watching the
directorial and writing debut of josh
dumel thanks for the call
thanks for the call thanks for having me
buddy always you know that uh have a
great holiday have a great
holiday that's josh they're right back
at you josh jumel
joshdumel on both twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisens show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here